welcome to this video oh la la okay from
Spain can I do something and let's do
something else not Queen twins gambits
all the time let's do some dream pawn
opening okay yeah what is it that they
do here with black very often they play
age six and okay so can I go see for him
trying to yeah i saw that Queen a five I
saw that I one known probably this first
yeah this is why I was hesitating for a
moment but i thought that i should i
should have some kind of compensation
Yemm okay night be five yeah might be
five is not possible unfortunately takes
pawn takes Queen Nia three years Queen a
five check this is not not going to work
huh interesting so the issue is that my
my bishop is kind of exposed them I
probably have to rely on my development
first and foremost and a forum for night
if maybe yeah maybe be four mighty form
interesting position ja I don't know
maybe I should have prepared CFO under
the better an idea three first or
something so that I don't have to that I
don't have to deal with this in the
first place I mean I'm not saying I'm
worse or anything but maybe I'm first
night of three was was somewhat more
precise 25 or something are interesting
but now isn't night c5 a good movie
isn't as good
hmm how does he keep the pawn now the
thing is if I get this back on c4 I mean
I really should have a nice position the
structure with c6 and before those
exposed pawns they give up the square c5
and ce4 yeah well see for their still
upon but still black gives up control of
as he find if I get the pawn back now
without any hassle I would have an
excellent position okay now he's he's
basically returning the pawn um okay
yeah come on hello take it that's not
easy not an easy position fam yeah so
it's there something direct them I mean
queen bee three for example isn't this
good or this is a very shaky position
that he has yeah this is good right he
cannot play you 64 quite obvious reasons
and f7 is hanging em champ
so I can take f7 first right and only
then takes you five there is no reason
not to check i guess
okay I don't quite well okay he was from
be afraid that my night would just just
jump to d4 or something along these
lines kb should be six on now that's
good right there's really no reason to
to take on age six this is just a very
bad night on h6 yeah i know but i
thought that Quincy for intending Queen
f4 was already really strong
you can give this check would be three
but I don't think it matters really
Queen f4 is very strong
I can take and queen is six but I mean
not immediately of course but but what
you see exactly if it if I just castle
here yeah come on Fletcher's castle I
mean this is just no position at all
with the King on a fade and no
coordination whatsoever
taking and bishop age six maybe that's
not not totally convincing but okay it's
it's certainly enough but this is
strongly stronger right taking f5 and e7
and e5 so basically everything
ya can take f5f for is also quite good
look g8 might be might be something that
can concern me
yeah I mean it's okay it looks like
every move wins this kind of thing but
it's probably not that every move wins
there are still some some probably that
are not winning
going 47
now you can play Quincy 8 and I'm not
I'm not threatening Bishop f6 yet but I
can just um I can just move the king oh
is that better batam you know I'm not
sure it's really not not the best
possible way to play I'm pretty sure
about that I can yet I've got a head
what's this possible really could have
played I've played that maybe I don't
know check late jam it feels like I
should have won much quicker maybe I
made some mistakes then yeah I don't
know maybe c4 he wasn't perfectly timed
but I always should have some
compensation for the pawn I mean here I
definitely have some compensation I've
got 33 m pieces out and a for coming I
don't know every I don't really like
that for like the combination of
snatching the pole and fee and shadowing
is somewhat strange will be really
difficult for him to not lose see
forward if he loses this is this bag
then yeah here the computer already says
white wins with 95 which is probably
probably true I am age 3 is also very
strong here but this is also can also
winning on tags tags there should be six
Queen 85 ok computer wants to play Roxy
one
maybe also intending Roxy foil well but
this is just i'm pretty sure that it
didn't play the best possible way of it
as long as I kept a winning advantage
I'm okay with that yeah it always it
always is a win tianqing edge one yeah
yeah well he couldn't do that because of
just having us here now here yeah and
it's winning yeah it's simply this
wasn't good yeah winning this pawn and
then the thing is that i can always get
in a four and it's difficult now he
cannot just keep those this chain he has
to play before I mean this kind of thing
is just not working at all oops I'm
sorry it was too much yeah so it's
difficult to not advance but here you
see that c4 really is very weak and it's
it's difficult to keep I mean this is
what I thought might be the toughest try
to activate the Queen here for some
concrete counter play maybe here i was i
wasn't sure i was thinking this might
also be a move this year but then he s
III you're right okay this is an
interesting way just for Roxy one but
then this is not so clear right i mean
yes this maybe or maybe this smooth
that's not clear at all the computers
gives wise a slight advantage but
nothing special and here he'd already
approaches very dramatic proportions I
just threatened to take e 6 NC 4 what
are you doing to do about it when you
cannot do this this is just outright
outright losing I mean this is kind of a
this is just crazy this is what the
computer is giving here yeah this is
just great for white I mean it's equal
material I'm better develop this is weak
and he has no coordination and I'm going
to get her that going to gain further
and further time this kind of thing is
just fantastic yeah he probably
shouldn't take the porn it i don't know
it looks very very difficult to defend
them okay hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching